Is that there is no law,
any law above, well, the,
the will of Polish nation.
That's why we have elections in 25 days,
but we have referendum the same day.
And we just let Polish people to say,
do you want legal migration,
which is forced by European Union, yes or no?
So, if Polish nation will say again,
and I must say,
since 2,015,
our party won 8 times.
We have won 8 times,
leftist were rejected 8 times.
If we gonna win for referendum will be very, very clear.
There is no law above the will of Polish nation.
And the most important is safety.
We want our women,
our children to be safe
and we gonna keep our word.
We promised in 2000 and fifth at 15:00,
not even one will come to Poland.
We did not let anyone in illegally
and we gonna keep our word. Dominic,
that language used in this country would be written off.
Well, we've been called by,
listen, we've been, and,
and, and we'd be told we kicked out of the,
kicked out of the, um,
we've been called by a dog,
called a racist.
They can call us a pink elephant.
I don't care.